en argentina a la primera vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales francesas
tienen lugar este sábado entre las 8 y
las 19 hora local en tres centros de
votación aquí en la embajada francesa en
la ciudad de buenos aires- también en el
liceo francés en la ciudad de buenos
aires- los dos centros donde votan la
mayoría de los franceses en argentina de
diferentes provincias aunque también hay
un centro de votación en la provincia de
mendoza para los ciudadanos franceses
que viven aquí en mendoza en san luis y
en sanjuan otras dos provincias
seguramente por la cantidad de franceses
dedicados a la industria del vino en
mendoza una gran productora vitivinícola
en argentina en argentina según datos de
la embajada viven entre 15.000 y 20.000
ciudadanos franceses y para esta
elección hay registrados cerca de 9 mil
900 para votar menos que en 2017 cuál no
eran 12 mil aproximadamente los
ciudadanos registrados para votar en
esta elección la participación aquí en
argentina de los ciudadanos franceses en
la elección fue del 26 por ciento
veremos cuál es la participación este
año en esta primera vuelta electoral
francesa